now keep in mind speaker pelosi defied
the biden administration by going to
taiwan so why is president biden so weak
on china does it have something to do
with hunter and his lucrative business
deals or maybe joe's years-long close
personal friendship with president xi
or could it be that biden is just weak
and ineffective joining us now with more
is the host of the monica crowley
podcast monica crowley along with
gatestone institute senior fellow gordon
chang you know we've we touched on this
uh with uh our first two guests is that
it seems perplexing monica about
joe biden's inability to act it seems
not just on china but almost on every
other issue unless of course it's
hurting the american people
do you think that this is really a
personal problem that joe biden has when
it comes to
his dealings in the past with china and
that it keeps him from being able to do
the right thing
well remember timmy that president obama
his boss for eight years once said never
underestimate joe biden's ability to
bleep things up and then robert gates
who served a number of presidents as
secretary of defense said that joe biden
has been wrong on every foreign policy
issue for the last 40 to 50 years so
again this is no surprise joe biden's
always been a hack but now he is
president of the united states and
america's commander-in-chief and there
is evidence that the biden family has
benefited tremendously from the ccp and
chinese communist party related entities
to the tune of well over 10 million
dollars so the ccp and those entities do
not write those kinds of checks without
expecting something in return so
obviously there's a lot of speculation
tammy as to whether or not this
president is compromised and if so shame
on joe biden for putting his families
and and personal interests ahead of
america's national security interests
and ahead of the american people this is
why you know we have tremendous weakness
in dealing with this fundamental
existential threat to the us the the
threat that the ccp poses to us tammy is
far more dangerous than anything the
soviet union presented to us because the
soviets essentially presented a
one-dimensional threat which was nuclear
and it was existential the chinese
threat is a hydra headed threat it's
economic it's military is geostrategic
it's in terms of flooding this country
with deadly fentanyl and other drugs
killing hundreds of thousands of
americans this is a multi-layered threat
and this president is crippled in so
many ways that he can't and won't take
them on you know it's remarkable and
excellent analysis there gordon uh
clearly your background in understanding
the nature of the beast of china that
they are everywhere they've planned uh
so far ahead of time
that it seems unlikely that somehow
america would allow
someone let's say behold into china
become the president of the united
states at this period of time but maybe
it actually is perfect considering
what's been dealt with and delivered up
until this point what's your take on how
we where we stand right now
i think we're in very
very perilous waters you know tammy the
problem right now is that inside china
there is a debt crisis
bank runs mortgage boycotts coveted
lockdowns and that means xi jinping the
chinese ruler has an incentive to
distract the chinese people from his own
policy mistakes and that means china is
lashing out in it we think about taiwan
of course because the speaker's visit
but right now china is also moving
against india the philippines and japan
those missile launches a few hours ago
they land five of those eleven missiles
landed in japanese water and that is an
extreme provocation well and in addition
to obviously still the relationship
between china and north korea and north
korea's pressure on on japan as well a
clearly
our key relationship there in that
region do you think that and north korea
seems to be wanting to get some
attention but that is almost ignored by
this administration do you think north
korea is going to pop up in the midst of
this presenting another uh larger
existential issue
yeah analysts right now are thinking
that the north koreans will detonate an
atomic device soon and we got to
remember that although they haven't done
it for a long time they got to validate
their test design so they will pop one
off in the not too distant future and we
know you know monica thank you sir we
know that of course iran has an interest
in what uh north korea has been doing it
seems like this now becomes this
interest by this
a trio of countries by by these
terrorist nations if you will uh to want
to act now quickly in the next year and
a half uh as the biden administration
becomes weaker and more troubled here at
home
yeah and there is close coordination and
cooperation between russia china and
iran as well as north korea sort of on
the fringes but they're all working hand
in glove and all of america's enemies
understand that they've got a pretty
limited window of opportunity here tammy
to act and to advance their own
interests at the expense of ours they
know that congress is likely to change
hands starting january 1st maybe both
houses so there might be some additional
restrictions but they also realize that
they've got another two years under this
president or a successor before there is
a change in leadership at the top in the
us and so you know you can't really
blame america's enemies for seizing this
opportunity you know they'd be negligent
if they didn't but they also know that
the u.s is not going to retaliate in any
meaningful way because the
commander-in-chief doesn't uh is not
going to pull the trigger in in any
meaningful way so of course they're
going to take this time and frankly if
the u.s is down for the count then our
allies are down for the count and there
is tremendous concern in the region in
japan south korea the philippines
australia a lot of worries that in fact
they're on their own because essentially
they are yeah we heard about that
certainly after afghanistan indeed
especially concerns from taiwan about
being on their own so we're excellent
reminders thank you both very much hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else